it's like yeah he stole my baby's mom
married her moved into my house and then
robbed me
wow all of these things holy [__] like
first off wait you're gonna leave me for
him damn all right let me at least call
home my key doesn't work you guys are in
there oh going back to his car I'm
robbed damn dude what
when you say you robbed him what are you
mean
probably one of his house and stole
everything and what are you gonna do
about it
and walked out
that's exactly what happened my
stepdad's best friend knows
nose
that's the thing when you're friends
with a [__] psycho things go wrong
psycho but they didn't friend since I
was 10. Oh and before he did that to him
he doesn't play by rules like that
something happened I said Dad's not a
scandalous person something happened
where he felt playing and goes
everything you have is not mine I'm
gonna take your life now that's exactly
what happened like that beard shaving
I'm gonna grow beard